all right thank you all another big
story we are following tonight liberals
Democrats they continue to mobilize
against president Trump's pick for the
CIA director her name is Gina Haspel if
confirmed by the Senate she would become
the first woman to lead the CIA to lead
that agency California Democrat Dianne
Feinstein she is now calling for the
public release of documents on hospitals
and violent involvement in enhanced
interrogation and detention of radical
Islamist terrorists following the
attacks in the murder of 3,000 Americans
on 9/11 Feinstein is only the latest
liberal lawmaker to question whether
Haspel was too tough on jihadis and by
the way it's not just lawmakers
attacking hospital joining us now with
reaction he's the host of war stories
all over North without enhanced
interrogation there is no bin Laden true
or false mr. Ollie north well the folks
that are currently resident down in
Gitmo wouldn't be there but for what
Gina has fell and her brave colleagues
dead look Gina Hass Bell is the person
needed to head the CIA in this New World
Disorder without going through all the
litany of what you went through at the
very beginning of this broadcast this
woman spent 30 years as an Operations
Officer with numerous foreign postings
she is quite frankly admired by most of
her colleagues I've not talked to
anybody to headquarters currently or
what was there who know or who don't
think the world of her Dianne Feinstein
ought to retire now
look she's grandstanding about
waterboarding when it was deemed to be
legal by the Department of Justice the
Attorney General and the president
United States in other words she did her
duty who was only afterwards that they
decided it really wasn't lawful and I
think I know a little bit about what
it's like what happens to people who do
their duty and Congress disagrees
congressman rather have you been
waterboarded in your life in your career
in the military as a Marine that served
his country and had to have a Purple
Heart go - I think - look I was a sere
instructor survival evasion resistance
and escape I used to teach it I was
waterboarded when I went through the
course I waterboarded at least a hundred
and fifty people some of whom I'm sure
right now wondering what the heck was
going on because it was all
illegal before we used to do it for
training we used to do it to people when
it when you need to be prepared for this
kind of thing I guess that that was all
stock
I stopped as well now all that ended for
me I hope it ends well for the new DCI
Gina Haspel the president and our
country needs her right there and they
don't need to drag her through what
other way if you have somebody like KSM
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed the mastermind of
9/11 the worst attack in American
history on our soil killing 3,000
Americans obviously declaring war on
this country is there a nice way to
extract information if we build the
soccer fields and we take care of the
dietary concerns and and we order
personal chefs for those on the
battlefield that are trying to kill
Americans is that gonna work well I
don't know I've not been involved in
anything like that I've certainly seen
people questioned in the field when
they've been captured I've put some of
that up on your show from overseas all
you had to do it is some of these guys
was to tell them through the interpreter
this is a high-value target has just
been grabbed by a special operations
team and I put this on their own yeah we
couldn't show the guy's face of course
by the way there is a report that I that
I haven't confirmed it that this woman
who did not oversee the waterboarding of
Abu Zubaydah if you remember yeah look I
put guys on on this air from overseas
who had just been captured okay and all
you had to do to some of those guys
would say ship him to good mo in in the
local language where there was Farsi or
Arabic and they were on curfew right
there in the spot all right safe home my
friend God's appreciate you
Semper Fi HSM perf I don't forget more
stories this Sunday night a PM Fox
Business Network